to a republican texas congressman who
wonders how these folks are ending up in
his district and no one's telling him
what's going on august fluger is his
name he sits on the house foreign
affairs committee among others
congressman thank you for taking the
time were you getting any word on this
well neil thanks for having me and the
reporting on this
uh can't be understand overstated enough
that you guys are getting the word out
and no we're not getting a heads up on
this it happened to my district last
year we did get word from border patrol
that there could be a possibility dhs is
basically
forcing border patrol to plan for these
types of events because they're
completely overwhelmed and when i say
forcing they have no other option and
let's let's keep in mind that 2.9
million encounters have happened 800 000
known got aways
since biden took office it's
unacceptable and there's a huge cost to
our country yes economic and i can get
into that but also national security
let's let's also remember that for 9 11
it only took a handful of people to plan
that and since biden has been in office
over 50 people who have matched up to
terror watch list
have been apprehended what about the
guidaways
so congressman when they get to your
district or towns in your district
explain the process to me how are they
processed where did they go
well that that's the exact question that
i want to know from secretary mayorka
says what's your method of planning
where are you going to drop them off in
the local communities what's the plan
for them just where are they going to
live how are they going to
get access to lodging and all the things
that are required just to sustain life
and those are the questions that are not
answered by dhs we have not received a
reply
but quite frankly the system is
overwhelmed
and the towns that they're going to
are overwhelmed the whole system whether
it's the official side on the government
and dhs side or the ngo side
is overwhelmed because like i said 2.99
million encounters since biden took
office
so finally i guess i'd like to get a
gauge the administration will send them
beyond the border to points north in
texas i get that they don't share the
the governor's deal with sending the
points far further north than just texas
to washington d.c delaware some of these
other points do you know if that could
change
well that's what we're trying to
understand from the secretary you know
where is he choosing to send these what
cities are being considered obviously
when we had the initial indication that
this could happen in my district we were
very concerned
but you know we say that every state and
every city is a border state and a
border city
the cost to americans is it's
incomparable
and we need to understand what their
plan is and this is a symptom the fact
that border patrol agents are even
having to think about this
is ridiculous they need to be thinking
about the national security mission and
making sure that all of our communities
are safe the fentanyl that is poured in
the amount of crime the drugs the
trafficking it's it's enormous and it's
unacceptable we need to get back to the
rule of law we don't need new laws we
need the executive branch and president
biden to enforce the laws that we have
on the books right now
congressman thank you very much keep us
posted on this i went to brian kilmeade
i want you to do me a favor i want you
to click to subscribe to the fox news
youtube page this is the only way that i
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe
right now